before we go any further i have to let
you all know that this video is
sponsored by best buy hello everyone i'm
alana and welcome to my channel um
first up sorry about the weirdness of
this setup it was the best lighting
option
that i had here we are i am in fact
still stuck outside of the united states
and that is very relevant to this video
which is all about vr fitness which i am
a very big fan of
but first let me give you some context
if you didn't already know this uh in
2020 i was very fit
gyms were closed
but the gains
were real i was doing training with
resistance bands i was using some
weights that i had bought um all at home
but i credit most of this
to
the oculus quest 2. so then in january
of this year that all fell apart because
i got into an accident where i um
collided my knee with a road at about 60
kilometers an hour and i couldn't walk
for a very long time it took months
before i could walk properly there were
weeks where i couldn't walk at all and i
only actually just now
have been able to start properly putting
weight on it by which i mean
doing squats again like only just in the
last
couple of weeks so while i've been going
through this rehabilitation process i
made videos about how i gained a ton of
weight how i went from
some of the most in shape that i've ever
been to gaining
loads of weight which i still maintain
that i'm not at all ashamed of or
anything but it does concern me
health-wise
um especially because i have asthma and
my asthma tends to get worse
the more i weigh so the inability to
walk or use my legs definitely led to
the fastest weight gain that i've ever
had in my entire life i was also just
sad and sore and wanted pasta so
don't judge me okay
it sucked
however i am now
successfully on the road to getting back
in shape do not want to understate how
important diet is i try to eat a lot of
fruits and veggies i eat a lot of nuts i
try to avoid
things with creamy sauces and breads
as much as i love them
they make me feel like crap but yes of
course diet being super important i
credit a ton of it to the oculus quest 2
and my number one favorite workout app
which is supernatural vr because i am
all about encouraging gamers to get fit
especially as someone who was
overweight and unhealthy eating bad food
and playing video games
in my early 20s
and then came full circle to treating my
body better still playing a lot of video
games with the biggest shout out of all
time to best buy for hooking me up with
my newest quest to
and with supernatural vr before we even
get into that though some things that i
want to tell you you need a facebook
account to set up the oculus and
download games or play demo games and
the app is available for android or ios
you do need to make sure you have the
headset properly adjusted so it doesn't
move around too much while you're using
it but there are also instructions for
that they do also recommend a 6.5 by 6.5
feet of space if you have a smaller
space you may need to just use
stationary mode however headset setup
will help guide you last but not least
attach your lanyards to controllers and
always secure controllers to wrists
during use so this is what supernatural
looks like you can log in every day and
see new workouts from all of the
different trainers who use the app and i
have a personal favorite i really like
leanne the title cards will give you an
idea of like what the kind of vibe of
the workout is but you can also get
specific difficulty reading so you can
know if it's a light workout a medium
workout or a hard workout and those hard
ones trust me they get real hard
welcome to quick hits game time i'm
coach doc let's start your warm up with
a slow high knee bringing that knee
above the waist good balance here now
we've got two hip hop tracks that are
set to boost your confidence and have
you prepared to come out of that tunnel
onto the field ready to play so i've
jumped into quick hits game time here
and as you can see we've got our little
triangles which is uh basically making
you do lunges and then you'll see coming
on the screen we have black and white
icons to hit
with each of our hands not only do they
get you moving very quickly there's also
a surprising amount of range in it you
do have to sometimes reach really high
and then duck really low there are moves
where you swing and the screen changes
because it is a full 360 game so you're
getting kind of a core workout in there
and it really really works your
shoulders to hit them as hard as you
possibly can even when you feel like you
don't want to plus i'm sure i'll let you
know the song is playing right now a big
upside is that a lot of them will come
with songs that you know and probably
already really like and that's honestly
pretty much it they do sometimes have
meditation or stretching um so a couple
of different modes but it really is that
simple it is so easy for anyone to pick
up and play but i do want to give the
context that
i recorded this footage back in north
america because the game is currently
only available in north america and
canada
[Music]
it's really really hard and gets much
harder or easier if you need it to but
overall
it's tough
supernatural vr uses the same dance like
arm movements that i like in a whole lot
of other vr games but the thing that
really gets me
is the amount of squats and lunges it
makes you do in a short span of time
without you even really realizing that
you're doing that now beyond you know
seeing how it works uh people do ask me
all the time
about working out in vr
what it's like how i manage it while
traveling so here's some of the stuff
that i use
okay so this beautiful thing right here
is my carrying case it does come with
something extra special inside of it but
just for the outside i'm a big fan
of how sleek this case is it's really
light but it also is hard enough that i
feel like my quest is never gonna get
damaged but let's get to the treasure
and sideshow
this thing
is the elite strap i know it looks very
strange by itself
these straps on the side are for
stabilization
the back end of this helps with advanced
uh weight distribution and is also very
comfortable like that's one thing that
had uh kind of been difficult for me to
solve previously is that you know
wearing anything on your head for a long
period of time can get kind of
uncomfortable
this really helps it makes things very
comfy and definitely more evenly
weighted extra cool thing about it
though is that it also features an
extended battery
the quest 2 is actually pretty great on
battery and one of my favorite things
about it is that you cannot touch it for
a week and then come back and it still
has all that charge pretty much every
time but this is a built-in battery that
sits on the back
of
the elite strap that lets you play for
longer it's awesome and you basically
shall i connect the two first up is that
you have to disconnect your phone from
your headset which i should mention a
lot of people ask about in terms of
cleaning you can get this thing out
really easily you can see that there's
sweat on it
from when i've used it just now you can
also replace it but i've also taken this
one out and cleaned it myself your
regular quest two straps
basically just come off the sides
and pull them up
voila in a similar fashion these guys
just pop on
whole thing is kind of together
you take the strap
you loop it through the part where the
um original strap would have gone and
then pull it up
once all of that is done
then you can pop your phone back in
which is very easy to do for the record
it just clips in and clips out so this
cable obviously
um is is where you
plug in your regular charger for your
oculus quest 2.
that sits in right there battery is
right here and there's also
this handy device on the back
so that you can adjust backwards and
forwards
really easily i love this thing it's
great the other thing a lot of you are
going to want to check out is the oculus
link cable i just got a new one of these
um and it basically connects the oculus
quest 2 to a pc i recommend this more
for when you're not working out but it
basically takes the quest to
and turns it into
a vr headset
that's powered by a pc it's fantastic it
is a
sleek little cable but let's open her up
anyway
voila
a cable so obviously a really important
thing about this is the length um for
anyone who wants to connect it to a pc
it's five meters so it's going to be
very easy for you to have your oculus
plugged in and connected to your pc
without worrying about what the chord is
doing and it's pretty much exactly as
simple as you would think that it is you
plug
one part into the side of your quest and
one part into your pc
that's it
it does also come with um which i'm a
very big fan of i feel like i always get
screwed when people don't do this this
guy right here this little velcro strap
that allows you to properly strap the
cable to the side of your quest too so
that when you're playing it's directly
connected basically so you know exactly
where the cable is you know it's
attached to your head at all times that
you are controlling what the cable is
doing it's pretty handy stuff when
you're in vr so there you have it i just
wanted to give you guys a little bit
more insight to working out with an
oculus quest 2
give everybody an update on how things
are going with me there and just show
that i feel like it really genuinely can
be very fun
you can own a gym a boxing ring a dance
studio and even a climbing wall all
inside of an oculus quest 2. though
supernatural vr
is the game that tends to consistently
burn the most calories for me there are
a whole bunch of other fitness games
that i also play that i have spoken
about on the channel here as well and
again a huge thanks to best buy for
sponsoring this video you can check out
all of their oculus quest 2 gear by
clicking the link in the description
below let me know if you have any more
questions i will see you guys next time
bye